in today's episode I'm going to answer
question from one of my readers Richard
who is launching a new website and
wanted to ask my opinion on a certain
website called buzz blogger to be able
to help him get the word out and spread
his message virally so he asked my
opinion on the site I've never heard of
this website so we'll see what it's all
about and if it's a service he should
user not to promote his website if
someone put a cold hard loaded gun to
your head and told you to generate three
thousand subscribers over the next 30
days what would you do alright so right
there they've already lost me I'm gone I
don't know anything about this website I
don't you know really like the messaging
at the beginning here unless this was
referred to me by somebody that I know
personally who's had some success I'm
probably gone I've seen a lot of these
types of sites that perm on the promote
and promise you you know all sorts of
traffic and you have to pay to sign up
and then don't deliver for anything so
if I were you I would not do this how it
goes somewhere else try to look for
other ways to generate traffic or ass or
recommendations from people who you
trust who've been in business we've had
success and ask them for their opinion
if they've had any success with either
this one or other other services so just
like you did you ask me if I've ever
heard of it so you know I haven't I
haven't heard of it at all I haven't had
any success with it and I would not
recommend using it I try to go somewhere
else if I could so quick video I hope
that helps if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below and if
anybody has heard of this and it has
some success please leave it in the
comments if you haven't I'd love to hear
what you have to say to if you want to
leave a comment on the video and stay
tuned for next episode
you